but [__] your feelings won't make a
woman abide by you and submit to you
when you say that no of course not
because then you go crazy counts are
productive you just don't say [__]
videos you've got to do it in a
different way like hey oh listen take
that emotion put to the side pin that
let's come back to that later yeah I
just like I just know fans I just think
you have no business telling them how to
run a podcast without a million Subs I
just think I would I would never go to
an NBA coach and like as someone who
like I don't know what you do with your
platform I don't know how big it is I
know you probably don't have a million
Subs yeah
again again so so I just would never go
to someone and tell them how to do it
when I'm here I just think there's a
level of humility in that no I know